المشاهدين تغيير كلي طال المسؤولين عن
القطاع المالي في تركيا فلم يكن محمد شمشك
التغيير الوحيد في اردوغان يفكر بتعيين
حفيظه غير اركان المديره التنفيذيه في
بنجوجمان سكس الامريكي كمحافظه للبنك
المركزي التركي بحسب مسؤولين اتراك وهي
واحده من المرشحين القلائل لخلافه رئيس
البنك الحالي شهاب وهو الرجل الذي قاد
السياسات غير التقليديه بخفض اسعار
الفائده وذلك من اجل محاربه التضخم لكن
السؤال كيف كان المنح الاقتصادي لاردوغان
بالرغم من ان تركيا حققت قفزات اقتصاديه
كبيره منذ العام 2002 بعد انهيار مالي في
التسعينيات واستطاعت لجنه تضخم الا ان
اردوغان لم يستمر على هذا النهج الاقتصادي
الذي بدا به
فاسرار الرئيس التركي على خفض اسعار
الفائده لتعزيز النمو الاقتصادي بينما
كانت الليره بامس الحاجه للدعم اضعف
رقبتها بنسبه 80% مقابل الدولار سلسله من
المسببات ارتبطت بسياسه اردوغان التي تسبح
عكس التيار الاقتصادي العالمي اوصل البلاد
الى تاكل القدره الشرائيه عند المواطن
وطبعا ارتفاع تضخم
ما الذي يواجه الاقتصاد التركي
انخفاض قيمه الليره التركيه
ضعف احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي
تمويل عمليه اعاده الاعمار افرازال الذي
ضرب البلاد
ارتفاع معدل التضخم تاكل القدره الشرائيه
ما الذي يجب العمل عليه
تنفيذ سياسات الاصلاح
جذب الاستثمارات الخارجيه رفع اسعار
الفائده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات